hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the evolution of addiction
medicine survive or thrive I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
brought to you by Carolina liquid
chemistry Carolina liquid chemistry's is
an iso certified and FDA registered
manufacturer repackage ER and the
labeler of chemistry instruments and
reagents Carolina's test menu consists
of over 100 reagents ranging from urine
drug screens to general health
assessment for more information please
visit Carolina chemistry's com we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speakers dr. Franco
sorrow and Carlos simpler dr. Socorro is
a board-certified psychiatrist
practicing for over 30 years his private
practice is located in creve coeur
missouri he is the founder and principal
investigator of millennium psychiatric
associate a clinical research company
conducting clinical trials and
Alzheimer's it's freni a depression and
bipolar illness is clinical associate
professor of psychiatry at kc um be in
kansas city dr. sacra founded de hairen
fund a charitable organization very
active in supporting clean water
projects and medical missions in third
world countries it's been serving as
president of the organization since 2007
Carlos Templars
Liza's in service operations business
strategy and corporate development he is
an executive level strategist with
extensive experience leading new
business development and service
operations his helps organizations we
organize and simplify business processes
to maximize market share and customer
delivery performance as well as
executing business development
strategies to penetrate and expand key
markets mr. Hendler has orchestrated
joint ventures business startups
reorganization mergers acquisitions and
integrations to achieve sustainable and
profitable growth they have had pnl
responsibility over multi-million dollar
businesses is currently health care
consultants for some position practices
and hospitals across the country mr.
Hitler has first-hand knowledge of what
it takes to set up a clinical laboratory
and has set up the number of
laboratories for his clients I will now
turn it over to dr. sacra for his
presentation so thank you ello everyone
i guess i've been very well introduced
and you know we have a slide that care
today that looks a little bit the how
does a addiction medicine has evolved in
lesson of the pretest pretend to go into
details and in you know that this isn't
a topic that has been extensively
addressed by many many in point of views
and we just want to do a little bit of a
general outflow a word what has happened
and were we going and because obviously
we need to change the future and you
have to understand the past and we have
to act in the present and so let me go
through this I like to present you with
some of these slides and some of them
I'm going to spend a little more time on
and for the sake of time I'm more
interested in the question and answers
and really want to give you my personal
clinical experience
so you know over the years the addiction
has been fluctuating between being
mainly a social problem or mainly a
crime or mainly an illness or mainly a
moral problem and so as obvious is
obviously that you know has implicated
in immensely in our society probably
with the era of prohibition is intended
to 19 29 to 33 has been a big
contributor to the developer the most
powerful crime organizations so it looks
like prohibition ism is not been in the
greatest on the other hand up you know
other get others you know approaches
have about taking a little bit more of a
social as well as a religious approach
you know we all want to remember that
the book of alcoholic anonymous
published in 1939 and has a very strong
religion religious background and later
you know very agencies have been
developed to address the issues of
either alcoholism or drug addiction and
just in the late 50s a little bit of a
medical approaches was introduced with
ant abused so a AAA membership became
the main source of relief for people
that were seeking recovery from
addiction and in the 50s was extremely
popular a lot of the organization were
funded and definitely became the
hallmark on how to approach it no in the
60s you know medicine medical approach
with a concept of disease became more
and more popular and we lived in a
hybrid in which counseling more moral
or ethical decisions were kind of
overlapping with medical decisions and
this medical model took on a little bit
more with introduction or methadone with
introduction of payments from the
insurance company realizing that this
was a complex disease and needed to be
approached not simply not a counselor
level but also a medical level now the
diagnostics of became more more
complicated in the DSM which is
statistic manual for diagnosis was
developed in the late 70s and in the 80s
specialized clinic for addition namely
Betty Betty Ford became kind of an all
mark of what to do to deal with it so
more more Monica plug-in by grants and
by ii by the government as well as the
insurance reimbursement in the 80s and
the famous concert of the 28 days
recovery was developed and then i'm back
in the middle of the 90s and all
traction was introduced as a spin off on
a lot naloxone is an anti opioid agent
they will prevent people from developing
and maintaining addiction so a purchase
were different and the continued to be
different was educational counseling
trailer incarceration very very popular
as well some form of punishment and
definitely medication was part of it now
you know we live in an area which
probably integration of these different
models is really necessary and you know
obviously we have to be able to be
flexible enough to understand the
addiction is a multi-faceted problem and
therefore is God social policies
involved with it and that
the insurance policies monetary policies
mental health issues you know i do
remember in the 80s a lot of the times
when a medication or mental health
approach to the illness who was kind of
frowned upon them mostly times as a
typical alcoholic analysis meetings if
somebody will show up with some form of
benzodiazepines they will be
sophisticated so things have changed and
even mental illness has changed a little
bitty approach and so at the end you
know this addiction becomes a real stays
really a puzzle it is a behavioral
problem is a social issues we we
probably have a combination of all of
those but what I like to also stress out
is that there is more and more sign so
that is coming out and try to figure out
what is behind addiction why people will
suck with something that they cannot get
rid of and becomes a driver for their
life so part of that is the fact that
you know there are aspects of our brain
that we totally are no knowledgeable of
you know it is say that it's possible
they're probably only ten percent of the
brain chemistry's understood at the
present time and there is more and more
specific diagnostic and
electrophysiological testing they
continued to be developed in order to
address this and so in this integrated
behavioral model I want to share with
you a little bit of our experience and
I'm going to skip through town some of
these slides because I found them you
know probably self-explanatory and but
one thing that has happened with us is
this in the last two years three years a
mortality rate for cardiovascular
disease as well as the cane
sir has actually declined what does it
increase there is the suicide rate and
what has increased unfortunately the
concomitant which is the fact that the
prescription of narcotic medications of
strong physicians has also become and
and and therefore abused by people of
medications or narcotics has escalated
and so the suicide rate and the abuse
and the passing of the so-called medical
opioids as a main source of problem for
for addiction is become really in the
last couple years a main problem in fact
you know the the National Institute of
addiction is really taking a little more
attention to that so at this point we
know that we have a need that we help we
know we have some statistics we know how
dangerous this is and quite frankly I
gotta tell you that we just lost to one
of our patients yesterday morning most
likely from overdose of prescription
medication so this hits really home of
fairly often and he is a kettle practice
probably more often than he showed
because of the fragility of our
population so we really need to take a
harder look what kind of the
professional intervention we can put in
place in order to identify patients that
could be i addicted the oracle use
addictive medications even though we may
feel that they may need it but known as
the service would that degree and i
always like to use this little example
you know we all love automobiles you
know where they bring us around we have
the capability having fun with them we
have different models so we can change
them but the reality is when
we are driving this beautiful machinery
that has changed our life in the last
century so much we also driving a weapon
and similarly you know mortality for you
know car accidents and you know the cost
the societal cost of this weapon is a
significant or so somehow these
painkillers that you know a lot of
practices use or there's a narcotics out
they do have you know maybe the beauty
of relieving pain and making life a lot
easier on the other hand could be deadly
weapons so you know obviously you know
the medical model is really complicated
not knowing enough about the brain
chemistry we have really very few tools
so to address it and I mentioned a
couple of memory anti opioids as well as
the antabuse so lately we like to look
at this in terms of wellness and or
simply treatment because at the end if
we combine you know the need for health
and the need for well-being we probably
have a better understanding a very
better projection of what the what the
issues are and obviously we have a
health care reform of trying to address
this and politicians are trying to
address I know permissive ism or not you
know recently my jaan has been
liberalized in some state and sometimes
a nobody really talks about all the ill
effects of using marijuana but you know
essentially i think we are faced with a
with an issue we have to identify people
that may actually be abusing in front of
our eyes we have to identify a system by
which we can engage them into the
program that allows them to wean
themselves for out of this and also
sustain that improvement so in this
prevention and wellness activity that we
want to prove
oh that a medical level we can include
many things in our intensive outpatient
program which we have started a few
months ago we like to look at the
disease management but also the ability
of preventing harm as well as promoting
self care as well as promoting something
that personally I like the most and
which is meditation and yoga and so in
this recovery model things are getting
more and more complicated and we have a
proliferation of sight were you know
medical models on the psychosocial
models are approved and also alternative
models are approved unfortunately you
know the recovery rate is very very low
so we have a long way to go but at one
point until we decided to engage
ourselves indeed in the in the ability
of you know defining what the what the
problem is and obviously we don't know
if this particular individual come in
the office do have abuse or they using
excessively certain medication or drugs
so we decided in our officer to take a
step forward and say well you know from
now on if I like to continue treatment
until we medications are potentially the
dangerous I really want to feel that I
have you know a dashboard what was going
on with your life so part of our
dashboard is ready to be able to look at
their chemical use and eventually
chemical abuse so we decided that there
was good for us to take a laboratory
experience and bring it into the office
and change a little bit of routine or
our office and we using the toxicology
in the land
in order to you know create you know a
monitoring system but also give people
the sense of collaboration and helping
them through control of their problem
you know I was in a consultation the day
before yesterday only 74 years old
barber who as the first thing he told me
and it was in the hospital for heart
problems the first thing he told me that
he was struggling to get off the daniks
for so long and he and the signs that is
now hooked on it so this is something
that hits home literally every single
day and just this morning occult on a
council today 18 years old they tried to
overdose people want to get rid of a to
be afraid they take the life with it you
know it just a constant reminder while
important disease so we decided our
office to do after that and also offer
the ability of referring them into
intensive outpatient program into
rehabilitation program and creating a
little more of a continuity of care and
engaging also the family so what I would
like to for the second time and also for
the sake of your attention to the pass
on the baton on is a Carlos simpler he
has been very helpful in my office in
setting up the ability of laboratory
monitoring and there's a horrible
problem with it is a drug abuse drug of
abuse drug / use a drug dependency drug
debts and so with that I'm going to just
have I Carlos on and and continual tell
us how your line yes thank you dr.
Sakura you're welcome hello everyone I
hope everybody's having a good afternoon
so far you know when we went out to the
core and I was asked to the co-host this
webinar you know the one of the things
that we wanted to do
as offer our personal experience in the
process of how we went from a behavioral
health to die opiate addiction treatment
and also our experience on how we
started or created the clinical
laboratory so that's what I'm going to
do is I'm going to share with you our
experience on setting up clinical
laboratory um the reason why we decided
to practice to go ahead and pull the
lavatory service in house was for a
couple reasons the first reason
obviously being it's more convenient for
the patient and that's very important
these days these days people have the
opportunity to to go to different
centers see different doctors so you
need to give them an ollie card but you
need to give them the best possible
service so this gave us the ability you
know to be more convenient for the
patients the second thing and I and I
can't stress how important this is but
it's probably the most important factor
is having the ability the controlled
operations and when I went on describing
control operations I'm not talking about
you know us working with a lot of the
lab director or us controlling the lab
technician what I'm discussing is the
ability to be able to obtain the results
in a timely fashion usually when you
know when you work with outside
laboratory you're lucky if you can you
get the results back you know within a
week but for you know for the diction
centers or four for psych consultations
sometimes you need those results
immediately but you know within that
that that timeline because if the
patient wants a script you need to know
they're taking other medications or
they're taking the medications that are
there being prescribed so when we
started the clinic laboratory it gave us
the ability to to be able to run the
tests immediately if we need those
results okay so now I'm going to go and
start discussing about the beautiful
experiences we've had on creating the
on-site clinical laboratory okay as a
practice or as a hospital or ask a
addiction center you need to ask
yourself you know that one big big
question what is the practice terminal
once you determine that then you're
you're smooth sailing but let me break
it down for you and tell you what what
we determined was our terminal starting
the laboratory there's four questions
that we end up finding out that is very
important first one is how much space do
you actually need the second one is how
do you find a qualified lab director
third one is you know how do you
properly bill and collect for laboratory
services fourth one is how do you find
qualified personnel to run your
laboratory okay so let's let's go in
depth in and kind of break down those uh
those questions I brought up the first
one you know how much space do we need
okay so on slide you know I'm here on
slide 44 you know I pretty much talked
about the saturation process but I want
you to see that you the CLC 720 from
Carolina liquids chemistry this is to
analyzer we currently use in our
practice in my laboratory and then also
for not consulting firm as well um the
dimensions for the CLC 720 4627 25
inches so as you could tell you
definitely do need a dedicated space for
your laboratory and that's obviously
detains of the hyperplastic Leah but you
don't need that you don't need a whole
room or you don't need a large large
space so a good thing to think about is
you know the dimensions of 4627 and 25
okay that'd be it said questions two
three and four you know how do you find
a qualified lab director when I say
qualify
director I meaning a medical director
who has experience in laboratories or a
so the third one is how do you properly
build a collective laboratory services
and then fourth one said how do you find
qualified personnel to run to let the
laboratory I can feel like a lab
technician now those three questions the
reason why I didn't break the down the
three questions those are items that can
be centralized by using outside services
outside consultant groups or firms who
specialize and who specialize in
laboratories and that's what they do I
can't emphasize and tell you how
important it is that you know as a
practitioner or s even addiction center
it to be able to outsource those
components it's actually in our nature
and you know with doctors especially and
hospitals too is that they they feel
that they can do everything themselves
that we can control we could do the
service we don't need to use another
service I found from from my experience
in developing different medical models
is that outsourcing and using firm and
in this one I would say it's very very
important because you know you might you
might not choose the right equipment you
might be spending too much on supplies
and reagents and etc or you might have
picked the wrong device so now you're
the time to take it at the time for the
test is taken four five and six hours
rather than where you could take an hour
so staffing is going to go up so there's
a lot of projects or singh of items you
know two three and four um okay so I
want to look what this is a 45 on slide
point five kind of demonstrates what a
typical in-house lab setup would be kind
of self-explanatory the pathologist here
is to get
that's your your lab director and that's
the one that's valuable it's hard to
obtain so the consultant services can
help you attain a pathologist or a live
director the one very very important
aspect and item that I want to discuss
about having successful lat it's also
choosing the right equipment choosing
the right chemistry analyzer it's
extremely important the reason why I say
that it's two questions I learned from
trial and error is that the questions
you ask yourself is how many samples are
you anticipating on running one the
second one is is what type of essays are
you looking to run and let me I'll
review those two and say why it's kind
of important for that the reason why we
took that we went with the co 720
analyzer as you can tell on the slide
I'm showing the reason we're for its two
things in it at the time we were running
probably about 200 300 samples a month
obviously we increase in said but at 200
300 samples you're in that that middle
area where if you buy the wrong
equipment if you buy two small of
analyzer you could be you could run 30
I'm 30 and they could take you four
hours rather than you know the device we
have the CL c720 they can run up to 550
that's per hour extremely valuable for
us and as you tell 550 that's why I'm
going to help us on a two to three
hundred because which was built and
still performing a test either weekly or
sometimes a variant on deck so it
obviously that extremely important
something to look for the second thing
is is that you need to always look for
but CLC was very good is that the amount
of essays they can run so for the CLC
720 they could do up to 90 different
essays and those essays range from the
chemistry essays to drug monitoring us
they even also go as far as forensic
essays as well too that's something that
we really don't as a practice kind of
use and in a determined but that's
always something going to know that you
have a lot of different tests that you
can run from a from your analyzer the
third that was extremely important is
that the required space needed was a lot
smaller using the CLC 720 than it would
be if we obtained another analyzer that
that was a that ran the same that raid
550 but but was a lot larger space for
us is very important and that you know
as you guys being a practice you know
that every that you got to utilize every
space possible the fourth thing was
something I determined once we started
actual you know performing the
confirmations and I start going into the
nitty-gritty of the labs services was
the CLC they have the best software
design that i could see so far when i
say that is usually when when you have
your lab services you have to buy we
call an l is system and if you guys have
used at l io system you know how
expensive they are I mean some range
just to get the web portal just to start
a web portal you probably look at about
50 ml then if you want the complete lis
system you probably look in 100 125
thousand with this system they have a
build in software design that was so
easy for us to use that our lab director
or medical technician can just hit a
button when it's done and we'll pull up
the screen for us and tell us you know
they tell us that how you know the value
and the run of how much you know in
their system important and again that's
kind of our experience that we have with
you know starting a clinical laboratory
and I'm glad like again Dodgers score
brought up what happened yesterday
because those kind of scenarios you know
you have to have that ability of be able
to run that test that moment and that
you know it gives us a little feathered
cap their centers other other offices
you know they don't have that that
pretty much wraps up our slide I guess
we could turn it over to some q 2 q and
A's okay thank you for the informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question could be for dr. to curl
or Carlos what made you choose Carolina
liquid chemistry for your supplier
probably you know Carlos that may answer
this is a little bit mind if I can
callate than me okay the reason why we
decided to use of Carolina liquid
chemistry's was that their service so
far would I see that customer service is
before the best some of these large key
factors you know once you buy the
equipment and they set it up they're
gone you'll never see them again with
care line of liquids they gave us the
ability where you know we call them and
we having a technical issue expect well
immediately but the other thing is is
about the the essays and the reagents
that they produce and the manufacture
and sell there's such a wide range of
essays that we can happen again you know
we don't just do drug monitoring we also
do such CBDs we also do cardiovascular
diabetes some hormone testing they offer
a wide array of of essays that you know
that other manufacturers don't
okay um what are some kick Falls for
starting your own laboratory this is
actually a two-parter what are some
pitfalls for starting your own
laboratory and why did that not deter
you from doing so this could be for dr.
Karl or Carlos yeah that's that's
interesting the diode up his laughing
right now um you know that we actually
got we actually this happened in default
dr. Socorro wanted he wanted to stay
away from having another service as
badly as as a plate and because of
certain events that happened and
honestly you know we only have an hour
discuss but a certain events that
happened we had to pull the service in
house but when I tell you and the Dodge
Sakura would amid this now that was the
best thing we've ever done it took a lot
of work and it took thousands of hours
of myself to learn the process to become
an expert to learn the regulations
because we you know one of the pitfalls
is people don't understand the
regulations of revolving or evolving
having a clinical laboratory like for
example how do you obtain a high
complexity clear um the second thing is
is you know understanding the technology
enough where you're running a certain
amount of volume and you don't need a
run a test every day so you know using
have you know using a great device by
the seal c720 I can run I could have my
my technologist one you know one day a
week and then I cover I'm saving so much
on expenses so you know money is a
problem too that's everybody knows
because especially right now that the
reimburses are getting cut every year
you have to find different ways of
saving costs so there's so many you know
there's so many other variables and
other third one let me bring this up and
right when I have it is that the
constant changing of regulatory called
the climate every month every year
something new is being added
either from s or private insurance that
someone has to stay on top just to be in
compliant so those are some of the
pitfalls that I can pursue but some of
the pitfalls describing starting young
lad but again you can there's help out
there you can you you can feel free
always a call me if you have question
but there's its own services who do all
this for you and put it like in a you
know little bow and tied up for you so
you could you guys do best and patient
ok next one is why did you choose an
in-house lab over instant rug test cuts
neck be for either okay I guess you know
that's a good very good question you
know yes what it is is it you can
probably drug test here your patience if
you suspicious of your nonsense [ __ ]
that and you know get a general I
getting a little kit you know yarn kit
and you know the problem with that is
this we let me give an example you know
so I have a patient is already taking
you know Ritalin or adderall or one of
the psycho schema very common in this
site practiced as a augmentation therapy
well you know it's good to know they
don't sell it so it's good to know to
have a test to be done but sometimes
people is not enough they can me for a
visit they may take it take one pill to
bill so it shows up positive so when we
do the testing also we do the
confirmation we have the capability of
that of elucidating you know the amount
so the other day the miners petitioner
came in and she say i look at this blood
test we have a 50,000 level of ave to
when we are given only 20 mils of a
dural it is obvious this individual is
popping around he's getting from
someplace else so you know the mysteries
await you know we we know the maybe from
a lot of us close of a practice we we
have this handsome
that is you know but at that point you
have to be able to say you know you know
if you if you find that somebody has a
high cholesterol level you know what are
you going to do you know we're going to
give them a diet that's perfect you know
you want to also show what kind of
cholesterol you have so you know the
detail of the other test you know aids
you in in clinical decisions and so
that's really been the driver and let me
add to that that was icicles mentioning
there's two other things that i noticed
wine being that the cups are really
unreliable the the analyzers is ninety
to ninety nine percent accurate and para
in describing of what type of medication
they're on so you know the cups they
were saying it as low as 30 percent he
that's very important the second thing
that a lot of people don't see but I
definitely see it on the bottom line is
those cups are expensive they're
valuable don't get me wrong with those
cups if they cost six sometimes even ten
dollars those kids and you know you try
to reimburse the cup enough with with
insurance companies a lot of a lot of
companies are starting to denying
because they're seeing it you know it's
part of the practice so you do have to
look at the bottom on as well but um you
know go more codes obviously the just
that it is not accurate so hopefully
then okay well I want to get people a
chance to ask more questions I believe
might look like some people are typing
so let's just give let's just get people
a moment here and see if we can feel
some more questions mm-hmm good give us
a brief hot true
in most few more seconds and looks like
lightning going on okay so I think of we
will we will wrap up I'd like to thank
our sponsor Carolina liquid chemistry's
for making today's educational webcast
possible we'll follow up with you on
questions we did not get to answer today
in the next couple of days today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through October 29 2015 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleague who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time bye thank you thank you
alright bye